[Music]
this doesn't feel good
oh man
see that guy that's hyperventilating
yeah that's me attempting to run a 5k or
3.1 mile race while wearing a full suit
of stormtrooper armor in this race there
were highs feeling pretty good so far
lows I need oxygen and some kids
bullying me
why am I doing this you might ask well
the reason is twofold one my friend
Caden said that I wouldn't be able to do
it do you think I could run a 5K in the
armor absolutely not no way and two
because I'm an idiot over the past month
I've been painstakingly building this
stormtrooper armor with movie level
accuracy so I can join the 501st legion
and I thought to myself I used to run in
high school I wonder if I could run a 5K
in the armor the issue is that this
armor is really uncomfortable and leaves
you with basically no Mobility I can't
even lean over really I wish the thought
of running in this thing had never
popped into my head but I have to prove
Caden wrong so let's go run a 5k I
should have known from the beginning
that this race was going to be nearly
impossible but like I said I'm an idiot
we're here
thank you
secured the package with the race packet
in hand it was time to get dressed now
you might be wondering why I look like I
was just slapped in the face and that's
because I decided to do this Challenge
on about four hours of sleep on one of
the windiest days of the year the wind
is brutal with this armor I'm basically
just like a big old sail the wind is
taking me away in actuality I'm running
this race to help build borehole wells
in Malawi Africa where people often walk
over two miles to collect water that
ultimately isn't very safe to drink this
local 5K race has only been going on for
five years but in that time it's helped
raise enough money to build 17 wells in
Malawi bringing access to Abundant clean
water to thousands of people every day
if you want to learn more or donate to
the cause I'll leave a link in the
description below okay when you warm up
right you can't really stretch so I
guess just move my joints a little what
do you guys think I love it you like it
first
sticker around or you're gonna get less
than 30. that's my goal and with that it
was time to start the race
[Music]
with the game plan I'm gonna try to
stick with the nine minute group for as
much of the race as possible and if I
fall behind I just have to make sure
that the 10 minute group doesn't catch
up to me now it's just me my armor and
the clock and my brother
but almost immediately after the race
began I encountered my first problem the
helmet so the biggest issue so far is
the helmet keeps hitting me right in the
nose I think I'm gonna have a black eye
after this also who knew breathing in a
helmet's pretty difficult
right now I'm not as worried about my
nose anymore it's more of the crotch at
the first mile I came in at 903 a lot
faster than I needed to be to meet my
goal
this is gonna be the hardest part of the
race the big downhill I know this hill
doesn't look steep on camera but when
you have basically no visibility it's a
bit scary to run down my biggest fear
right now the trip and ruin the armor I
spent a long time working on this not
gonna fall
so I used to be a pretty good runner
back in high school for five kids I'd
get around 17 minutes so I have eight
years later and one and a half kids my
goal is just to break 30 minutes so
we'll see if I'm even able to come close
to that so with a goal of breaking 30
minutes I need to be running each mile
at a pace of 9 minutes and 39 seconds or
less although I was probably going a bit
too fast at this point I was feeling
good so I kept up the pace this would
come back to bite me later on in the
race but for now I was enjoying myself
and then disaster struck
disaster my crush play unlooked it was
taking way too long and I was running
out of time we're just gonna run with it
on her I can't fix it right now now my
butt plates flapping all around but at
least my craft feels a lot better now
now I had to make up some time the wind
is brutal with this armor I'm basically
just like a big old sail the wind is
taking me away it's not looking good
at Mile 2 my Pace was still pretty good
9 17 but I was beginning to feel the
effects of the armor and the lack of
oxygen in the helmet I think I need to
slow it down a little more on oxygen
starting to see rings of black a little
bit
gotta challenge myself Gage helmet stays
on
[Music]
how's it going guys
keep it up
I need oxygen
the weirdest thing though my left big
toe is falling asleep I think the armor
might be cutting off circulation somehow
at this point I could really feel myself
starting to slow down I was getting cut
in multiple spots by the armor my legs
were beginning to lose circulation and I
was starting to get tunnel vision from a
lack of oxygen in the helmet but I was
always being pushed on by my friend
Kaden absolutely not no way I couldn't
let him be right I had to finish the
race so as I started to feel more and
more of the strain I saw there was
nothing left to do but keep going
what's up
as I needed the end I thought back on
everything that led up to this moment
and I knew I had it in me to finish what
I'd really like to say is you can do
anything you put your mind to including
running a 5k and stormtrooper armor for
some reason
and with that all I had to do was cross
the final Bridge run up the last Hill
and finish the race
[Music]
of course they put a hill at the end
then it's strong
[Music]
I finished with plenty of time to spare
on my goal oh that was that was really
tough I was starting to see black near
the end we did it I can't even lean over